all right i'm super excited about this i
i already told everyone i think this is
going to be one of our best
conversations here so please don't
disappoint no pressure
oh okay
all right uh maybe let's go through your
background first and then we're gonna
get into some actionable ideas around
what people can do to build passive
income uh and uh from an investing
perspective but what exactly is your
background how did you kind of build all
of this
well i started out actually as a
conflict journalist so i was running
around mexico u.s mexico border writing
about human trafficking drug smuggling
anything where humans had sort of
kinetic connection along a man-made
border and
i
got a little actually just
disenfranchised being a journalist is a
tough gig and you end up being excited
about terrible things happening to
people and and that didn't sound like a
good life for me and so i ended up
figuring out you know i was talking to
one of my mentors at the time and i
asked him my last name sanchez bunch of
other people across the border's last
name was sanchez i was like what's the
difference really and it's not american
it's not mexican it was like one
difference which is that i came from a
middle-class family we had some money
and so i was like well i think power is
really just money in a different form
and i don't know anything about money
and i need to learn about it so i
climbed up the corporate ladder and a
bunch of financial institutions you know
how do you know if somebody worked at
goldman they tell you in five minutes so
i worked at goldman i worked at vanguard
state street and then i ended up
building this relatively large asset
management firm at a firm called state
street uh got recruited to build one at
a company called first trust couple
billion dollars later and assets under
management not revenue um we had a big
business that was servicing a bunch of
people down south and the only reason
that i had the ability to do any of that
was because there was sort of i mean
it's what you guys did too you find this
opportunity between narrative
and numbers so the narrative is bitcoin
sucks you know 10 years ago or whatever
when you guys first started investing
and thinking about it it's too nascent
we don't understand it it's used by a
bunch of black hat hackers well latin
america was the same it was like oh
narco you know uh
cartels we don't want to go down there
so i was like actually the numbers look
great there's huge growth prospects in
the country i'm gonna go down there and
build it so i did sold out of my shares
there and then looked for the next
arbitrage opportunity which i saw in
cannabis so i started investing in
cannabis then became a partner to
cannabis a private equity fund
and continue to invest in that space and
sit on the board and then the next thing
i started looking at was smbs small and
medium businesses so where could you in
my opinion i look at this world today
i'm like god everything's so expensive
there's no value and i'm not smart
enough to compete in a place where
everything's expensive and all the
players are playing and so i saw this
opportunity in small and medium
businesses to start investing and buying
mom and pop businesses because big pe
firms play up here at least 10 million
dollars in rev and then down here it's
just us little guys to get to play so
it's one area of value in a big world
and so journalists to investment banking
to finance to private equity to now i
buy and hold companies i
can't really use the comparison of
warren buffett but like his hold co
structure is a similar structure that i
have now okay so we got a ton to get
into uh one of the ideas that you have
that i think is really really
fascinating is this idea of um 20th
century versus 21st century finance
what does that mean and how do you kind
of delineate between the two
well 20th century finance to me is what
our parents did it's one income income
stream it's again what you guys talk
about with bitcoin and crypto which is
it's all about decentralization right
you don't have a single point of failure
you have multi points of failure which
allows you to have more uh safety and
security amongst other things but it's
the same with incomes so what i see is
the biggest failure and the pandemic
proved it for all of us is that most
people one out of 100 people will die
wealthy the rest largely die
um sadly poor and i think the reason
that is is because they have a single
point of failure they have one income
stream and corporations they are
incentivized to make you have one income
stream right like employers do not like
you to have multiple jobs they do not
like you to be bitcoin rich and also
work at their company typically and so
that's 20th century income and finance
in my mind you have a single point of
failure that is your income you stay at
one place and you have a pension until
you die
and 21st century is what millionaires do
today 7 to 12 streams of income and you
used to think that that was so hard to
get impossible to get but it's actually
not today more than ever it's easier to
have multi-income streams in fact you
could do with a hundred dollars by
investing in something like fundrise
which is hard asset real estate in an
app you know you can do it by investing
in cryptocurrency and staking or earning
on top of them and having cash flow so
what i talk to people about is how can
you go from your one income stream and
use that one income stream to get you 10
or 12 because in my prediction it's
going to get worse not better and people
who only have one income will be the
ones left holding the bag when you think
about cash flow or income is that the
first thing like you need to have the
cash flow in order to be able to execute
any of these investing strategies
well you need
let's do it two ways one i don't like
deals where you don't get cash flow
right away that's why i'm not a big fan
of angel and best and we could talk
about that later but when it comes to um
investing today you i like to put money
down on the table and get money back day
one that's called cash flow investing
and we can talk about ways to do it it's
just that most people don't know how to
structure deals and i get it i only
learned this for being a private equity
but so so first thing is any deal you do
you should look for payment day one it
is not a good deal if you do not get
paid until 10 years because most angel
investments will go to zero not 100 x
and so you need to invest with that in
mind now you do have to have some money
to start investing typically or you can
use your sweat so it's either you have
equity or you have sweat equity and what
i talk to a lot of people about is even
if you're working with somebody even if
you have a job you like your job you
want to stay there you should be trying
to move towards ownership instead of
employment and you can do that as an
employee by asking for things like
revenue share where you take a
percentage of the revenue that you help
bring into the company or profit share
which is probably more likely
when you think about the first deal you
did walk us through how did you find the
deal how did you negotiate it and then
do you still hold it did you think about
selling it at some point like how do you
think about like what the end of that uh
that investment looks like
yeah so the first deal that i did by
myself completely
i still hold it was a terrible deal i
won't say the name of the company
because i don't want to hurt the
operator's feelings it was a terrible
terrible deal um i went and it's like
sort of the five tenants that i talk
about now i bought a company that was
too big uh because i was cocky uh and so
it could have broke me i could have lost
all my money doing this first deal um
the accountant left basically two weeks
in so i'm in like a dusty room full of
ledgers trying to figure out what the
heck is going on with the service-based
business um and they're a mess the
operator was not trusted talent or tried
talent meaning i didn't know the
operator and he hadn't done the job
before which is now something i look for
with every deal and then lastly i had
invested in what it's called a
turnaround business this is what the
biggest issue that young people do is we
get all excited we're like i'm gonna go
buy a small business look at that
laundromat over there it's a nightmare
it's dirty like the machines are old i'm
gonna totally redo all of it small
problem never ran a business before
never ran a laundromat before never
turned around in business before so
that's like the people who go and buy
houses that are nightmares and then they
want to flip it and their first flip is
usually a disaster because you have no
idea what you're doing
and so instead you should take a little
bit of the safer bet on the first one
and then go do it's called a hairy deal
then go do a hairy deal that's a little
bit harder as you go but that was my
first deal now 12 years later uh the
deal is profitable it's a win it's good
to go which is why i like to do i think
it was like naval that said not
long-term deals with long-term people i
like to do the same thing with my
businesses find good ones hold them
forever never let go of the cash flow
what is the process now in terms of
locating a good business right we'll
talk about kind of structuring the terms
executing the deal et cetera but just
when you look at a business is there
like a checklist that you have or
something you go through to determine
this is worth doing more work on and i
potentially could hold this for a long
period of time
yeah a hundred percent you gotta get you
gotta gotta have a due diligence
checklist um and that's what it's called
due diligence basically just means am i
buying a terrible business or is this
actually a business that i think uh i
fully understand what i'm buying and
like again because people understand
mortgages and this is more normal than
in real estate than small business
buying i compare the two so you know
when you go buy a house what do you do
you get an inspector to come look at
your house and make sure that it's not
just pretty on the outside but a total
nightmare within you do the same thing
when you're buying a business so you
know there's a pretty standard due
diligence checklist and you can look
online in almost any industry you want
to buy say you want to buy a car wash
like you love the idea of quarters in
you know money in your bank account
great so what you should do is you can
go on the internet very easily and you
can look up card
car wash due diligence checklist there's
a ton of them all over the internet i
mean i have some of my own that are
proprietary every pe firm out there
private equity firm out there has a due
diligence checklist too for every single
industry that they go into and you make
sure you run through the task lists just
like you would if you were buying a
house and then there are people to help
you call business brokers you can have a
sell side or a buy side business broker
that would be like your realtor real
estate agent and then you can also have
consultants on the type of business
you're gonna buy and they're pretty
cheap actually usually what i do is just
call up some other business buyers that
are not in competing areas and just say
hey i'm thinking about buying this tell
me your biggest mistakes and tell me the
biggest mistakes that i could avoid from
talking to you
makes a ton of sense uh i love the idea
that you talk about all the time around
just like knowing the language of uh
deals or knowing the language of finance
and how important that is uh especially
when you start looking at the difference
between uh price and terms i always joke
with people like i'll pay a billion
dollars i'll just pay you a dollar a day
until i until we're done right um and so
walk through a little bit as to uh what
your advice to folks is in terms of how
they could get much more proficient uh
in the language of deals or the language
of finance
yeah well if you remember this like one
line
you'll be ahead of 90 of people which is
um you can have your price and my terms
or my price and your terms but you can't
have both
and the part that you don't tell them is
that uh
if you control the terms you control the
price and so um i always try to push
people to understand the terms it's kind
of boring up front you know there's
these things like ratchets and warrants
and options and you know it can be
overwhelming when you first start you're
like you know cody i just figured out
what a mutual fund is and like how to
get in my robinhood account and now
you're talking about warrants and
potential options on future future price
execution like that's a little confusing
but quite honestly if you think about
finance here's what we're really good at
we are highly paid in finance and we are
highly paid we make you know two percent
of every dollar you give me in finance i
take from you if you invest in any of my
funds if i'm in private equity and then
20 of the profits of any deal we do i
take from you if you're in my funds
and that's how private equity is
structured and so everything in finance
is written and said to make you feel
dumb and people in finance feel smart
and the the truth of the matter is none
of us are rocket scientists and this is
all so standardized that if you take you
know a weekend to get to know some of
the terms you are going to be able to
run circles around not only your future
bosses but anybody you do a deal with
you've previously said angel investing
is largely dumb i think that'll be kind
of sticker shock to some folks what do
you mean by that
yeah i know i was talking to a couple of
my friends that just did rolling funds
right now and um similar people that you
know but um
you know the thing with angel investing
is i truly believe you should not be
angel investing unless you have two
things one a million dollars if you are
a
you know accredited investor with
actually a million or more
i think you are much better off getting
cash flow today and not trying to give
somebody money to fund their dreams
the only caveat i have to that is if you
have an unfair advantage
an absolute unfair advantage meaning you
work
in silicon valley or these days miami or
austin at some of the top tech startups
out there and you have an insane amount
of deal flow that nobody else can get
into or you have a unique skill set that
allows you to invest in deals that
nobody else can get into and and that
term proprietary deal flow meaning like
i have deal flow that nobody else has is
usually 99.9 [ __ ] and or crap sorry
i don't know what i can say here and
then also um the last thing i would say
is um most people who angel invest
it is you can make a killing if you have
unique deal flow a hundred percent but
for the most part you gotta do 10 20 30
40 deals to get there and if you have
less than a million bucks you're
honestly not going to be able to do it
and then what nobody tells you is it's
not just the 10k or 50k you put down
first all these companies raise a ton of
money so then you have dilution so you
better if you're going to invest 10k you
better expect to invest 100k to keep
your same percentage
you also say that public markets are
kind of dumb uh i agree with this one
for sure um explain what you mean by uh
public markets being uh maybe a place to
avoid
well i first started realizing this
because i looked at the forbes 100 list
and i was like oh i think i want to be
on there one day like how do we do this
and um and what i realized from the
forbes 100 list is nobody on there is on
there from public stock investing and
then people are like no cody carl icon
you know and you're like wait a second
actually carl never does
market deals you think carl's on his
robinhood account putting in his trades
no
carl is behind the scenes buying
secondary shares affecting the outcome
getting on the board harassing everybody
it's highly aggressive same thing with
warren buffett i mean i was at goldman
sachs when warren did that deal where he
invested in goldman and everybody was
like oh i feel good about goldman
because warren invested i'm like
long-term that was a good trade but
warren invested in a private deal that
was hugely different than you going out
and investing in the stock market
directly so
the biggest investors out there they
don't make their money from putting in a
trade and in a buy signal or using some
sort of technical uh stock tracking and
all the stuff that people talk about
with with even with bitcoin tracking
which you know about this so much more
than i but i giggle because they're like
look at this new amazing way that you
can chart the future price of bitcoin
and i'm like this is called
point-and-figure charting and we've been
doing it in finance for decades and
actually everybody stopped using it in
2008 because i was at goldman and all
our hedge funds blew up there were black
box proprietary text there's that word
again that was using point and figure
charting and got killed so
have money in the stock market but don't
expect that to make you a billionaire
because it won't how do you think about
allocating capital between the stock
market
private market deals like more angel
investing technology type companies and
then buying businesses that drive cash
flow for you
yeah so from an asset allocation
standpoint i'm a huge believer in
diversification which is like kind of
like yeah of course but um the problem
is most people aren't actually
diversified they have income streams
from one source 90 to 100
and then they over index in whatever
area they know the most about and people
are like but wait remember the book zero
to one peter thiel he's really smart he
said to do one thing
um i wouldn't go head-to-head with that
guy
but what i would say is if you make all
your money in real estate
or let's say finance so me in finance i
worked in finance for years and your pay
is highly correlated with what the stock
market does and then i realized wow all
my money's in the stock market and i
work in the stock market if something
goes sideways i am the opposite of
decentralized um and so what i started
to do was look at non-correlated asset
classes basically like if i own this
thing and the market goes up it goes up
if i own this thing and the market goes
up it goes down right
and um
and what you find is anything that is
publicly listed has a lot of correlation
they all do the same thing you know when
the market goes down all of them usually
go down and there's some caveats around
that right but these days my portfolio
is pretty broad-based i have about 50 of
my investments are in small and medium
businesses you guys talk about
pandemic-proof businesses as opposed to
recession proof which i think is a smart
uh differentiator um and uh and so i
have a lot of essential services in
there as well then i have a very small
percentage of stocks like 10
less bonds i have some crypto holdings i
probably need more and i have um an
allocation that's pretty big to real
estate hard assets commodities um and
other liquid asset classes oh and then i
hold a ton of cash um so we can talk
about that too why do you hold so much
cash
well it's a dichotomy today right like
somebody asked the question they were
like how can you
how is it that cash is king and that
also cash is trash because of inflation
and i was like the truth is it is both
it is literally both today you need to
have a way to protect the cash that you
have from inflation and the fact that
our government's printing debt like it's
going out of style or printing money
like it's going on style but you also
have to have cash because in my belief
you want to do what baron rothschild
said which is buy when there's blood in
the streets especially when it's yours
and so if you think like me that the
world will not always continue to be you
know at all-time highs eventually the
dance will end you want cash because
illiquid assets won't allow you to take
advantage of it and if you look like
it's actually i should have brought the
stats but you could google it um if you
look at
vc
private equity uh funds and the vintages
or the years that they start investing
during recessionary periods those are
always the best performing funds so you
want money that you can access the
second things go sideways which is why
you need cash but you also need things
to offset inflation like crypto real
estate uh different types of cash
flowing assets and small businesses
we've got a whole bunch of ideas that
you sent me in advance of things that
people can do in order to
buy businesses or sectors that could be
interesting for them to kind of get
started and make it actionable uh the
first one is modular homes and you wrote
just in all caps the future so what what
is modular homes in terms of being the
future and what do you think people
could do there
well i think we're a ways away from it
still so excuse the enthusiasm but for
instance i get really excited whenever i
can buy something that i'm a value
investor in a way a value cash flowing
investor which is not usually normal so
whenever somebody says there's a market
like real estate at all-time highs i
mean we just bought a property in austin
it's absolute chaos down there um
i'm always looking for how can i get
into the asset class but in the cheapest
way possible and so modular homes are
essentially these 3d printed homes or
built homes factory built is more
normalized that are made for
quite a lot cheaper than the average so
our house that we bought so we bought a
house in a mountain town and it's on
about an acre of land and with a house
it was like 3000 square feet i think the
whole thing was we bought about we
bought it for about 900k
now in this mountain town the average
home price is about 2.1 2.3 million i
can't remember the exact amount so
somehow i am able to get in at a bigger
plot of land and a great location with a
price tag that's about half uh more than
half um less than half of the price of
traditional real estate and the reason
why is because modular home developments
are new so modular homes you going out
right now and buying a factory home you
can see them they're all over pinterest
everybody thinks they look cool
but you do not want to buy a singular
modular home because it doesn't scale as
well what you need to do is go out and
find developers in the us that are
building modular home developments their
economies of scale for massive factory
printing will mean that you can buy at
one third to one half the price and if i
was a developer i'd be doing this all
day long because the factory built homes
are cool looking
they're much more efficient because
about 70 of construction is waste
it's absolutely nuts um there's a
number of businesses i don't want to
name any of them to give free marketing
but uh
in terms of the various businesses uh
one there's a bunch of efficiencies that
they gain so you don't get that waste on
kind of construction site but also too
is i think that there's a lot of
consumer
kind of preferences changing right
people don't necessarily need uh to live
in a city so there's more demand for
people who want to go live in some of
these areas and also too is what type of
home do they want right and kind of what
do they need actually do they need a
seven car garage probably not right and
so i think that you get a number of
tailwinds along with the actual unit
economics changing and it seems like
that's uh kind of a bet that you think
is worth taking
totally yeah i think um you know anytime
you get to invest in innovation at a
discount that's pretty wild
so i think that's an opportunity the
modular home space now i haven't found
that many companies that i would invest
in that are modular home builders yet
because they haven't figured out the
scale portion of it yet but i think if
you could do a factory built home and
you could own the land and part of the
development company you could cash flow
from it today but you could also benefit
from the potential innovation going
forward because wouldn't it be crazy man
i couldn't could you imagine if you were
like what's the brand of your house you
know if it's not like where do you live
and what you know what does your house
look like it's like oh no i live in a i
live in a a pomp house right because
just like everything else
would be scary just like anything else
everything will eventually be branded
and i think your house will be too yeah
makes sense uh laundry mats uh i
actually own one in a very weird way
much longer story uh but we own um a
partner and i own uh some of the real
estate and we also own uh some of the
business as well and they print cash
it's crazy
so what is the opportunity you think
from a laundromat and kind of how could
somebody go from i don't know businesses
to getting in this game
yeah it's funny i wrote about that on
twitter and it kind of went a little
viral then everybody's like so what do
you do for a living you just own
laundromats and it's like no that's one
of one of the things i own but but the
um the reason i talk so much about
laundromats is because it's accessible
when i go start talking about buying
businesses most people are like must be
nice privilege and it's like wait a
second wait a second the reason i talk
about buying businesses is because it
has actually been only done by pe firms
for so long and so we've got to start
with a business that is not so
intimidating and the laundromat it's
like you have a space you lease you have
machines that you utilize people put in
quarters and you print money on the
other side of it you got to clean up the
place a little bit you've got to have
somebody do some maintenance on the
machines but it's really not a lot more
than that and so um i like to talk about
laundromats because like you said they
actually they cash flow beautifully the
price for them probably it's worth a
little bit more now because i've been
spouting off about it for a while but um
you know it's usually two to three x the
profit so when you go to buy a
laundromat if a laundromat makes a
hundred thousand dollars a year you can
typically buy them for 200 or 300 000
and if people are like also sounds great
i don't have 300k lying around they
don't realize there's something called
the sba and the sba the small business
association will give you a loan for 90
of the purchase price of a business that
has books that they can track and
confirm the profits from and so
just like you could go out and buy a
mortgage and put 10 percent down you
could do that on a business if you were
to go and buy a house right now a single
family with a mortgage and try to cash
flow it the average uh single family
makes about 464 dollars a month
464 dollars a month is what you make
from putting down hundreds of thousands
of dollars in a laundromat i'm making
five 10k a month
it's a totally different game yeah it's
incredible mailbox money which is a
great name but what is uh what is
mailbox money how can you do it yeah you
need to have her on she's over she's a
riot uh so so a friend of mine uh lisa
song sutton um is similar to me we have
this idea of buying boring businesses
holding them forever and i think it's
that immigrant hustle she's uh like
first gen korean um but essentially what
it is is so
i was looking at the self storage space
lots of people are i think we're both
friends with nick huber sweaty startup i
was like this looks interesting it's a
way to get into real estate but with a
higher return on that monthly cash flow
we talked about because i'm always like
show me the cash i want to see it every
month but the thing with self storage is
now you got every buddy and their
brother in that space and it's become
overhyped and expensive for the most
part in my opinion
and so i was like so how can we do this
cheaper then i was talking to lisa and
she's like i own this mail center so you
know how you got to ship out a package
you don't always go to fedex or ups you
could go to like cody's shipping center
up the street or something right so i
always thought those businesses were
kind of interesting because the packages
and maybe they make a bunch of money
sending back and forth and all the chat
keys in the store wrong they're real
estate businesses they're mini mailbox
real estate businesses so you charge
anywhere from 20 to 30 to 40 to 50
dollars a month for a little po box and
the the key is ups knows that this is
the game so they mandate that you can
only have like 100 mailboxes in a ups
franchise i hate franchises by the way
so i never buy a ups but if you own your
own store you could cram 200 300 500 1
000
mini little po mailboxes in there and
every single one you're making 20 to 30
a month lisa's mailboxes sell out within
six months because everybody and their
brother's doing what we're doing right
we got llcs we got things we need to
send we're starting our side hustles and
so the business is booming but there are
not enough mailboxes that's mailbox
money and so when you think about that
business specifically is it something
where uh it's people in a local area
they come in to the physical location
they like get their mail out of the po
box or is there like a digital component
where then somebody's going into the po
box at the business and like taking a
photo of the mail and then people can
access it online like how kind of
digitally native or or digitally up the
curve are these types of businesses
versus literally just
we have a mailbox you rent it from us
come in get the mail whenever you want
and like leave us alone
yeah most of them are the latter so
digitally native is not normal in small
business at all as you know that's the
opportunity um i think so most of these
businesses and leases too they don't
offer digital services it is completely
you go in you check the mail that's it
um
and so that would be 90 of them the cool
opportunity i think on top of this is
you buy a business like this you buy a
pack and ship center you input
immediately those another 100 to 200
mailboxes so you've increased your
revenue by a few thousand dollars a
month um with a couple mailboxes that
cost you a couple hundred dollars to buy
and then on top of it maybe you do offer
that service especially in a place like
miami where people are having you know
potentially two locations or going back
and forth between new york and they just
want to make sure that their mail isn't
pioneer piling up you could have a
scanning service in that and charge it a
premium then you might be able to charge
a hundred dollars a month for a service
like that so i think those are
interesting but most people don't do
that
when you think about buying real estate
at auction how does that work
yeah so my friend aaron amuchastege is
amazing at this what what i try to do
and i think what people should think
about doing if they're going to get
multiple income streams you can't be an
expert at everything you know if i want
to go and really understand crypto and
bitcoin i would have to spend hours and
hours and hours and hours or instead i
could follow somebody like you and i am
a subscriber to your newsletter every
single day i could learn a little bit
more about the asset class and i could
invest alongside you in deals or i could
give you money in deals so that's
typically what i do with all these asset
classes i'm like all right lisa i'm
going to invest in your business over
here mailbox money aaron and muchastegy
i want to go with you and i want you to
teach me how to buy real estate at
auction this is so cool this guy came
from nothing
he has no like formal college degree um
super blue collar and he was doing what
everybody does in real estate which is
just selling houses back and forth he
flipped a few houses and then he found
out about this thing called real estate
foreclosure auctions and he's located in
the state of texas where they have a
they sell houses on the courthouse steps
so every single month they release a
listing of all the houses that are going
up for foreclosure and with that listing
you can comb through it and prepare to
go on the courthouse steps and bid on
these houses the amazing part is and
even in a market like this today you are
able to buy houses for let's call it
anywhere from 30 to 50 discount to the
market rate you can get actually a
higher discount if you go and knock on
the individual doors themselves to
actually buy properties and so aaron has
this whole thing where you know he's now
worth tens of millions of dollars he's
bought thousands of these houses he now
keeps about 250 houses or so
as rentals to cash flow and he bought
them all on the courthouse steps there's
obviously particulars with this like
you've gotta actually you need to do a
little bit of research if you're gonna
do something like this he has a book on
it i think the book's basically free um
he just does it to be a nice guy and
then what i love about this business too
and this is what i talk to more business
owners about doing he owns this real
estate foreclosure business right so
he's out there buying houses at auction
and anybody can show up to these
auctions it's totally free so you can
just go and check it out i've gone with
him it's really cool but then on top of
it he was like how else could i add
value to this main business and he was
like well what if i took a a sas company
that lists all of the houses that are
for sale right now that's a
subscription-based business that people
like him buy what if i bought that
business and then i put some money into
it and then had that business grow even
bigger so he bought his first sas
company and then he's like and then what
if i bought the the company that goes
out and does door knocking to try to buy
businesses beforehand and it has a sas
subscription model to it too geolocation
and stuff like that and then you bought
that company so those are called
roll-ups and i get really excited about
that in any industry
ancillary service roll-ups because you
can add one company to your already
existing company and that's the only
time i know people these days like to
say math isn't real but that's the only
time that one plus one actually could
equal three or five with strategic m a
when you think about um m a you've said
multiple times like you shouldn't build
things you should buy them
why that is like so contradictory to i
think what most people are being fed in
terms of like go start a company go
angel invest in companies why buy not
build
yeah well you can i think you have to
think about it from two perspectives so
if you have you know i don't if you're
um if you're the creator of ethereum and
you have this idea and you're like this
thing needs to exist in the world and
like i shall be the creator of it that's
awesome you should go start that
business
most people start businesses for money
they're tired of working at their job
they don't make enough money they want
freedom whatever the case may be most of
us work because we like getting paid
right and so what i like to teach people
is to divorce the two so instead of
building a business for cash flow if
what your goal is is to make money then
buy your profits don't go and try to
guess that the idea that you have is
going to eventually make you money
because that's often not the case which
is why you know we have more than 90 of
startups fail and the average
entrepreneur has a salary of 60 000 a
year
even as the ceo of a business for more
than 10 years think about that for a
second why would i go and try to do that
when i could go on some of these
websites like biz by sell flippa
e-commerce flippers when i could look in
my little local laundromats in my area
and see this business right here makes a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars i'm
gonna buy this business for 3x 180 k
using an sba loan and day one of me
owning the business i'm going to start
cash flowing 180k a year and then i can
take that cash flow and if i want to
create the next ethereum or whatever the
idea is i can do it from a place that
doesn't have to bankrupt my family and
these like war porn horror stories we
have of like i did it all for my garage
and my basement and then i lost it like
you don't have to do that
and in fact the average person just
wants their family and community to be
better and healthy and so they should
probably buy a business and not build
something or then build something from a
place not of fear and scarcity they can
build it when they have a little bit of
a cushion i've got my both my brothers
here and they've got questions for you
as well joe john what you guys got hey
cody thanks for doing this appreciate it
hey
uh my question would be really just
around getting started right i think we
touched on this a little bit earlier but
i think generally when people think
about diversifying their income streams
when it comes to passive income and
looking at different industries and
businesses they get a little scared that
they're not an expert at any one
singular industry right so how do you
think about starting to do that and
getting educated is it just partnering
with specific people in those industries
like you mentioned earlier or is there
another strategy that you think works
well
yeah well a couple things first i think
you should start from where you are so
like one of the first guys that i
started talking to about this and taught
how to do it there's a guy by the name
of mark and mark was a digital marketer
so he basically did ppc he did you know
helped people
buy ads and stuff online
and mark would charge i don't know two
thousand five thousand dollars a month
to run these ad strategies for companies
but a company's not going to continue to
utilize mark unless the two to five
thousand dollars they that he that he's
charging them is turning into 10 15 20
000 right he's got to make more for them
than he spends and so mark was making
these other people millions of dollars
and sure he would increase his fee but
you know he could only do it so much
until he wouldn't be competitive with
the rest and mark knew he was good so
what i told him is why don't you do an
acquisition
through sled equity and do something
called a profit share an equity
alignment for your work and so mark
ended up saying hey keep the 2 to 5k
instead of that i want 10 of the company
which equals the i don't know 50 000
you'd pay me over the course of the year
and i want 10
of the profits for the next three to
five years and i want 25 of the profits
for everything that we're gonna do this
year and so mark was able to actually
buy a business with zero dollars down
and using his sweat equity and now he's
a 25 owner of this business that nets
him a couple hundred thousand dollars a
year instead of his 50 000 so that's
step one if you have a skill that does
one of two things brings in revenue to a
business or helps decree cut decrease
costs for a business you can do a
revenue or profit share acquisition
that's step one all you do is change the
terms of your contract with them
the second would be if you're like an
accountant right
i think the easiest place to start is
you have a skill that you already know
accounting why don't you go try to
acquire an accounting firm or because an
accountant is a pretty incredible skill
skill for acquisitions you could account
you could you could
buy just about any type of business but
i like to tell people start where you
are so like one of the first businesses
that i bought
was a plumbing company and the reason i
bought it is because i had a family
member that was a plumber for a long
time and ran a plumbing business so i
was like i'm gonna buy this i know the
finance side i couldn't unclog a toilet
if my life depended on it but like you
know about things like that so let's
partner together on this deal so find
another person who is complimentary in
your skill set
like that john
yeah thanks cody for doing this i really
appreciate it um i actually have two
questions so one of the first ones and
i'll just ask them both and then answer
them at your leisure is um where do you
go to find already established
businesses so you're talking about the
laundromats and stuff like that um and
then also why do you hate franchises so
much
um
is it like the kickback what is it about
franchises that you don't like
yeah we'll start with franchises because
that one's fun i love controversy um
so uh i hate franchises one because i
hate being told what to do like that's
the whole reason that i
would start my own businesses and i got
out of finances i was an insufferable
employee like absolutely worst anytime
you know anytime you get in a business
people are like
yeah this isn't the right way to do it
but we've done it this way forever so
let's just keep doing that right and i
was i was always inept at being able to
say yes um and so i hate franchises
because they have massive rules so
anytime you're part of a franchise if
it's a good one and actually worth the
15 to 20 to 25 you have to pay them
they're going to have all these rules
and regulations and i'm kind of like you
know what i think i know better and i
don't want to listen to your rules so
that's reason one if you're going for
freedom which is what i talk about a lot
in owning a business why would you give
up some of that freedom to somebody else
to ultimately be your other boss i don't
like it
second reason is i don't want to share
my profits why would i have to share 10
to 25 of my profits with somebody else
and you might say well because they're
going to teach you how to do the
business well if they're going to teach
me how to do the business that's a
one-time
endeavor i can learn all of that by
paying a consultant up front maybe i pay
them more or maybe i pay another
business owner more to give me all of
his sops his his processes um but i'm
not going to pay that business owner 25
to teach me that for the rest of my
ownership of the business no thank you
and then third is i like to protect my
downside
and with franchises they can mandate a
bunch of things for you like i have
friends that owns mcdonald's franchises
and mcdonald's will say okay we're
rebranding everything we need new
signage everywhere here are the new
rules and regulations with covid that
you're allowed to do or not allowed to
do it's gonna cost you about a hundred
thousand dollars to five hundred
thousand dollars so go ahead and have
that implemented in the next 90 days i'm
not interested in that so that's why i
don't like franchises you can make a
bunch of money though so that is fair
um
i forgot your first question entirely
what was that again no worries where do
you go to find businesses so if you say
you're interested in laundromats where
would you go
do you scour the internet do you try to
network what do you do
so the best way to do it is offline if
you know like what what pomp is saying
is like well that's funny i guess you
guys are all pomp that's a little
confusing i never thought about that
before um okay so um
the the best thing to do is not to go
native not to go digitally native why
because that's the easiest path right
anytime you have the path of least
resistance you have typically uh the
least return and so the best way to do
it is actually this so the the maybe
like the second or third business i
bought
was uh and i just own a part of that
business i own about 40 business
that business was a service that was
provided to me it was in the media
sphere and i was paying this guy like a
pretty you know two thousand dollars two
thousand dollars or something like that
a month to provide this service to me
let's say that it was video production
and um
and this guy had a business that was
doing okay i could tell he kind of had a
job he he he had this business so that
he could have a lifestyle he was the
operator of the business he was in it
every single day and i was like hey um
you know let's call him tom tom do you
uh want to grow your business and he was
like yes stupid question of course i
want to grow my business and i was like
okay well i pay you two to three k a
month i think that i could get you
probably anywhere from 10 to 20 new
clients that were similar to me and we
could increase the prices and i think
some of your systems and operations
aren't that great and like you could do
these couple of things in your business
with 10x what if i invested money in
your business give me a look at your
books just tell me a high level how much
profit you make in a year i'll give you
a reasonable return you know anywhere
from you know 1.5 to 3x
the investment that i would make in it
and i want to own about 40 of your
business but i'm also going to help you
grow the business so we ended up doing a
deal where i only invested 10 000
in this business that was doing about a
hundred thousand dollars in profit
but i ended up bringing them about
another hundred thousand dollars in new
client and now i own forty percent of a
business that does three hundred and
fifty four hundred thousand dollars
something like that of profit a year
that is totally doable so look at your
look at your checking account and your
um credit card where are you spending
money consistently over time and do you
know the owners of those businesses can
you talk to them about can you invest in
their business alongside them i think
that's one of the most underserved ways
to find businesses and then the next
thing that you want to do is like talk
to your dad's friends like talk to your
financial advisor talk to your attorney
talk to your accountant and look for the
gray-haired wave which are all the
retirees that are moving out of their
businesses that are tired of coveted
lockdowns and you know this the move to
digital that don't want to do that
they've been running them for decades
and have face-to-face conversations in
your community then you can do it online
on some of the sites that i mentioned
before like biz by self flippa
e-commerce slippers etc
cody before we let you go uh the most
important thing to talk about i think is
mindset uh you've um been very clear i
think about uh having a different
mindset than most people um and as i was
preparing for this conversation i was
reading through a lot of the things that
you've written and if i had to sum it up
i think that we see eye-to-eye in that a
lot of people are complacent uh they're
soft and uh they basically just make
excuses right it's hey i can't do
something because abc you know thing
uh talk a little bit about your mindset
um you've got this line victimhood is a
killer which uh already people are
getting all worked up about probably and
uh and kind of just like why the mental
side of this or the um
perspective that you hold is such an
advantage when you're investing
yeah well i yeah i mean i think my joke
is you can um you can enter the race for
who's the biggest victim but you're not
gonna like the prize
and um and you know i think one of maybe
the only reasons i can still say that is
because i'm a latina and i'm a woman and
you know maybe that checks two boxes but
the truth of it is if we actually want
to help people and not race to who is
the best at virtue signaling um if we
want to help people we would never put
them in a victim mentality because that
tells you that you are small weak not
powerful and that the things that
happened to you um were not things that
you can overcome we would want to put
them in a victor mentality where you
have been through trials and
tribulations and difficulty maybe more
than other people maybe you've been
through atrocities but you are still
alive and breathing and so you are a
victor and that is the different
mentality and i think today more than
ever the saddest part is that
so many people get upset by that like
how would you get upset by the idea that
you allow somebody to name you a victim
and somebody comes along and says you
know what you're more powerful than that
i'm actually i have a bigger belief in
you and you can do bigger things and
people are like no
don't tell them that get them back down
there and i think that is the travesty
of our day and age is the narrative has
been so flipped so if you could really
take one thing away from everything you
talk about and all of you talk about and
i talk about it's not the tactics which
is a lot of what we talked about today
it's in every time you hear that little
voice in your head it says
i can't i i'm not smart enough i'm not
able to just flip it and instead say how
could i how could this work how could i
accomplish this and i wish more people
would do that i mean i'm i'm married to
a former navy seal and so you know when
i talk about tough it's comical because
like we do a workout together and i
about die um but what i've learned from
those guys is that men like when you ask
them what it takes to go through buds
none of it is physical my husband would
tell you it is yes you have to have a
baseline physical um foundation but it
is completely mental and it is can you
laugh like you he his his thing when he
was going through buds was every time
they would do something terrible to them
like go you know swim 400
you know miles and then roll around in
the dirt and then don't sleep for seven
days and they would get in his face
about and be like what do you think
about this he would tell him a joke and
he would laugh every time a difficulty
was presented to himself so to this day
every time he gets hurt he's always like
oh man that hurt and that change of
mentality is everything and i i wish i
could impart that on more people we talk
a lot about on the show uh not being on
defense but being on offense and
obviously you know there's some basic
things people have to do they have to
they have to have income they have to
get out of debt they have to kind of be
educated but being in that offensive
mentality uh i think is so powerful and
i'm gonna forget who says it um but but
i've seen the video multiple times kind
of go viral online where somebody's like
you know uh i wanna be in shape
go work out right i want to uh make more
money get a second job right it's like
this idea of like if there is a
complexity if you want there to be
complexity but the most basic level of
motivation and action is literally just
go do it and it feels like the investing
strategy that you take uh has some level
of you have to understand how to find a
deal how to vet a deal how to structure
some of the deals but there is an
element of just go look for a business
to buy right and whether it is um you
know what i'll call like the amazon
strategy that you employ which is you
know my cost center of video editing
should become a profit center for me um
it just feels like it's somewhat common
sense and basic stuff it's really the
execution that has all the value in it
yeah that's exactly right i mean at the
end of the day it's just get more owners
get more owners and less employees and
even my employees and the people that
work for me i'm always letting them into
deals and telling them to bring me ideas
and you know having them put more money
into deals um because that creates
loyalty more than any 15 minimum wage is
going to create and so um i think that's
exactly right and you know
a lot of people push back on this um and
it's usually for two reasons one they're
scared um and then two complacency and
so if you can get over the fear and
realize that you know pretty much
everything you want is on the other side
of the things that you're too scared to
do
and then you can get past the idea that
you're not good enough or you're not
going to be able to hack it i mean think
about all the free resources online i
think the maybe the other problem is
that there's too many options and so
people get paralysis by analysis and
they just sit and end up watching
netflix instead of it but um it's the
truth of it is none of this is as hard
as people make it out to be and
i think almost every hard-working human
could go and buy a business today you do
not have to be a pe you know expert or
savant to do it um flip side of this is
uh this is why it's kind of easy in
america at least to be successful
because so many people are willing to
tell you why it won't work and why they
can't do it and while they're making
excuses i'm making money and that's the
difference you you don't know who this
person is but uh we have a friend uh
danny boy hustle hard who uh
joe and i have gotten to know and and
john is a fan from afar and he
constantly posts on instagram now
usually with a great plate of food but
uh he will say you know america pretty
good country huh like you know come on
cheech pretty good country right like
and uh i love it because it always
reminds me of like yeah that's right
danny it's a pretty good country man you
know like we got it pretty good here and
uh you know taking that for granted is
pretty stupid for uh for those that do
that yep
yeah joe john any uh any other questions
from you guys no i'm all good
danny boy hustler is gonna be so excited
he made his way into an episode last
time we mentioned him on the podcast he
posted for six weeks about
uh all right cody listen thank you so
much for doing this where can we send
people uh one let's send them to the
newsletter and maybe twitter or anywhere
else you want to send them
i think those are the best i think um
newsletter contrarianthinking.com
this is where we do cash flowing ideas
and contrarian rants every week so if
you're into that um usually our
difference is hopefully i've done all of
these things it's not just theory so we
give you the actual play-by-play and
then twitter just cody underscore
sanchez also are you guys on tick-tock
because that is such a i mean talk about
anti-american that part i don't love but
talk about a growth platform we're also
now on tick tock so i think if you're a
young hustler tick tock's pretty good
for you
if you're more sophisticated check out
twitter
and if you want deep dives do the
newsletter
uh i have to ask are you and the rest of
your company doing
dances are you guys posting educational
content what is getting posted on tick
tock
this is how far we've fallen i did do
one of those stupid dance have you seen
this like this one like i did and i sent
it to my whole team and said you know we
have lost all self-respect
um
but uh but no that was my one and only
dance now they're like short snippet
videos about the ideas you kind of get
people thinking about ideas we have a
side hustle series right now and it's
like side hustles that don't suck
because most side hustles just you know
suck up your weekend and don't make you
any money um and so we have sort of 21st
century side hustles right up right now
which i think is just like great quick
snippets but i've been amazed at the
growth that's on that platform it just
goes to show the first mover advantage
for any social media platforms is real
yeah it's uh it definitely seems to be
growing incredibly fast so that's a
great tip for everyone all right i've
put the uh the link in the chat for
everyone to uh to go subscribe uh to the
newsletter but i i really appreciate you
doing this so much goes without saying
everyone really enjoyed it uh i have not
seen folks this excited about buying
businesses ever so uh your uh your
message resonated and we'll definitely
have to do it again in the future
thank you so much for having me can't
wait to see the three pomp brothers on
that tick-tock
somebody said a pomp talk house and i
stopped reading the comments
all right thanks cody thanks cody thank
you guys
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it